[Music]
hey I need you to concentration
the end is near I'm alright thinking
that the spider-man outfit is as we knew
it is gone now no well yes yes it is
basically essentially in this film I
have a new suit which Tony Stark gave me
it's an upgrade and it's too fantastical
to exist in real life so I essentially
there it is that's the first time I've
seen it where looks great God you came
tonight is that mikkel I don't know ok
we're essentially pajamas I wear these
pajamas with balls on them that light up
it's super cool it's not you know I'm on
set with the Avengers who are wearing
costumes that hundreds of thousands of
dollars made by the best seamstresses
you can imagine and I'm there in a soup
made by Marks and Spencers oh it's just
presses in English hey everybody I need
you to cause a distraction we need to
tell people about how we just got rid of
the old spider-man costume I love the
way that Tom Holland like he's not
spoiling anything really because we knew
that they were gonna be moving on to a
different costume but when he's talking
about wearing pajamas the iron spider
suit this is what that looks like just a
more hardcore version of the mocap suit
that he wore for spider-man homecoming
so they're like practical versions of
the suit then there are mocap versions
infinity war iron spider is mostly mocap
because it's such a hardcore suit and
because it does so many more things than
the original suit does if you are
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
there's gonna be crazy stuff posting in
the next couple of weeks it's gonna be
awesome
like you look at this spider-man
homecoming clip with him playing with it
it was a funny montage but you can see a
lot of these were done practically hey
Karen what else can this suit do Oh what
maybe we should run that refresher
course he even posted some of the
green-screen for that now what he's
doing is a little bit closer to what
Iron Man does like Robert Downey jr.
even joked about it in the clip that I
posted in my last trailer video earlier
this morning you know you're not in the
costume wouldn't when the helmet closes
I'm getting shiatsu the funny thing
about that is I was like you know promo
tours gonna be starting really soon this
is gonna be the biggest one that they've
ever done they're gonna be spending more
money to promote the movie than they
ever have in all kinds of different ways
so I was like you know next week we're
gonna start seeing a lot more funny
stuff
turns out no not next week later tonight
so because we're through March Madness
now I'm expecting it to be a little more
predictable but the really cool thing
about this is that it confirms
spidey-sense although they talked about
that at Comic Con when they first
announced him for spider-man homecoming
Kevin Feige had him on the stage
they were talking about all the cool
classic spider-man stuff that they were
bringing into it of course spidey-sense
is a big part of that and even though he
had it during spider-man homecoming they
didn't make it a core part of the plot
otherwise he would have been freaking
out before the vulture opened the door
[Music]
that's really that infinity war moment
here where Thanos is ship with the Black
Order on it comes into orbit for the
time gem the other really cool thing
about this too is that you see the
web-shooter act almost as if it has a
mind of its own kind of spider II like
it wraps around his wrist after he just
Yanks it out so even though it's all
stark tech they're making it very spider
like in the way that it looks the way
that it works the types of powers that
it gives him or the boosts that it gives
him because he doesn't have the organic
web shooters that Tobey Maguire
spider-man had that was actually a
Bendis thing he said when they got to
amazing spider-man Andrew Garfield era
one of the big notes that he gave Sony
was used the mechanical web-shooters
from the comics so there's just one of
the aspects of that character that
survived a modern-day Tom Holland era
spider-man there were a couple of you
that were asking me about Cindy moon you
know the silk character from the comics
she was a character in spider-man
homecoming but it was just like a normal
girl in high school it wasn't the actual
silk character so for those of you that
are asking about her during infinity war
or the other Spiderman supporting cast
members like Ned because so many of the
mains are in this from all the different
movies like the Guardians the Thor
movies everybody
most of those supporting characters are
only gonna be on screen for a very brief
period so when you're hearing about
spider-man characters those are probably
all people from this scene on the bus
they're on the class field trip he bails
to go help out the Avengers down by the
sanctum and as probably the last you see
them because I'm expecting most of the
post-credits scene tags to be either
Avengers 4 related or then just dealing
with the loss of whoever winds up dying
during the course of the film like what
do we do next and then in comes Captain
Marvel which is near the top of my list
for one of those moments like we even
just found out that Nick Fury is going
to be somewhere in the film I have a
feeling it will be Hawkeye bro
because Captain America hasn't been
operating with them he's been doing
Secret Avengers stuff on the DL Iron Man
and the rest of the regular Avengers
that sign the sokovia accords have been
operating aboveboard they haven't been
working with Nick Fury either u.s. Sam
Jackson what he's been doing this whole
time and he says he's been hunting down
Red Skull but that's just the actor
saying that the Red Skull is off
somewhere in a different part of the
universe so just be prepared for Nick
Fury to pop up briefly but it would make
sense for him to show up at the very end
like I don't think he's gonna be around
for any of this big crazy Wakanda stuff
he's just not quite as necessary it's
when they rally and he's sort of the
connective tissue to Captain Marvel
because of what we know about his
presence during the Captain Marvel movie
talking about the next spider-man suit
though spider-man as we knew it is gone
now No yes so we have like the classic
homecoming suit still kind of stark Tech
then we have the infinity war iron
spider outfit all of us expect him to go
back to a more classic cloth looking
suit for that next spider-man film they
don't start filming that for a little
while but they're ramping up now like
Tom Holland has already started posting
on social media can't believe we get to
do this again so they've already
revealed some concept art for what the
next version of the spider-man suit is
going to look like and for the most part
it looks almost exactly like the
homecoming suit albeit with some more of
those enhancements built in things
become more lightweight more modular it
gains extra functions that you didn't
see the other suit so remember it has
suit Lady Karen AI inside of it so for
the most part we saw the spider light we
saw the spider parachute that comes out
of the back the drone that comes out of
his chest
the reconfigurable gauntlets four
different types of webbing and the
instant kill mode which is still a bit
of a funny moment I don't know if
they're gonna bring that joke back
around during infinity war okay I'm
gonna get a little closer so I can see
what's happening would you like me to
engage enhanced combat mode or enhance
combat mode yeah
activating instant kill thanos rolls up
activate instant kill mode can you just
wonder why Tony Stark would build that
function and they built it in for that
joke I don't think that Tony Stark ever
intended for Spider Man to kill anyone
but don't you just wonder within the
logic of that
somebody had to design that then add it
to the suit so at some point iron man's
like you know what I'm gonna give him in
instant kill mode because of all the
stuff that Leticia Wright said about
helping spider-man with his suit I'm
wondering if he makes it to Wakanda at
some point at the very end of the film
and that begins their collaboration and
that's how you slowly get to the classic
looking suit for that next spider-man
film but that is all that extra
functionality that you saw in the iron
spider outfit and think about it this
way if we're getting this hardcore iron
spider outfit in these Avengers films
what's it gonna look like when we get to
the next Avengers film because there's
always gonna be more Avengers films and
as long as Sony REE ups the sharing
arrangement with Marvel after the second
spider-man film he'll be in that next
Avengers film meaning that he'll get
another really cool upgrade so maybe by
that time we'll have some fantastic for
future foundation it would be really
badass to see him in that white costume
but that's so far down the road is a
little early to start speculating about
it I know everybody's asking about
symbiote I've already made some comments
about how sure II can give him some
vibranium functionality to his suit so
let me know in the comments after
Avengers 4 he puts away the iron spider
outfit what do you want that classic
suit to be able to do like what kind of
functionality do you want it to have
what'll happen is is because I wasn't
expecting this there'll be more Avengers
later this week people have asked me to
do a video for more missing characters
or surprise characters that I think
might pop up leave all your requests in
the comments below and I'll name a new
giveaway winner when I post new Marvel
but click here for that Iron Man trailer
and click here for brand new Deadpool
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight